so i'm really depressed about uh what's
going on in pennsylvania um as many of
you know we've been following the
pennsylvania senate race as i'll show
you in a moment the control of the u.s
senate after november after the midterm
elections could depend on who wins in
pennsylvania because of a number of
different dynamics and realities about
who's up for re-election and where are
their open seats and this type of thing
so we're very interested in who's going
to be the next senator from pennsylvania
on the democratic side i have been
leaning very heavily not that i vote in
pennsylvania but as an opinion i've been
leaning heavily towards john fetterman
the lieutenant governor
and on the republican side the story has
been that television dr mehmet oz
is running as a republican
and he has some celebrity donald trump
has endorsed him etc well last night
there was a democratic primary debate
and a republican primary debate and i
found both debates extraordinarily
depressing we're going to look at some
clips of the republican part i wasn't
able to find clips of the democratic
side but i watched it yesterday and
it was just really depressing so
fetterman whose policies i like
seemed
disoriented confused
he was slow to respond he didn't make
any sense it it was a terrible
performance where when i watched the
republican debate my thought was any of
the five candidates running on the
republican side would do well against
fetterman so while i like fetterman on
policy
his debate performance was terrible
um in terms of the other candidates on
the democratic side there was a woman
khalil i believe her last name was um
and then a younger guy named malcolm
kenyatta and then conor lamb kenyatta
had some good answers but at one point
simply said no when asked whether he
wants to answer a question he said no
and it was bizarre
and then conor lamb clearly the most
polished in terms of media preparation
but a very uninspiring kind of
center-left establishment democrat
it wasn't like wow one of these people
would crush a debate against these
republicans so that was on the
democratic side
it wasn't thrilling to say the least on
the republican side it was straight up
sinister disinformation i mean just
absolutely crazy and we're going to look
at a couple of clips first of all the
debate opened
with an argument over who's really from
pennsylvania based on how long they've
been in pennsylvania here's a little bit
of that 70 percent of republican voters
said the amount of time a candidate has
lived in pennsylvania is important we
begin with mr mccormick you've been
campaigning on your pennsylvania roots
but you have not actually lived in
pennsylvania for the last 15 years so
explain
why it seems that you returned to the
commonwealth just in time to run for the
u.s senate mr mccormick you have 60
seconds thank you mr oz uh except for
your time attending medical school and
graduate school you have not actually
lived in the commonwealth in
pennsylvania so how do you respond to
concerns that you do not know what is
best for pennsylvanians you have 60
seconds sir so so the first question
everybody just talked about how long
they had been in pennsylvania okay i
mean yes the voters claim they care
about it but it's already not actually
substantive
then there was the trump sucking up
portion of the entire thing where trump
endorsed dr oz and so dr oz in basically
every answer would mention that but
every candidate tried to suck up to
trump that was the next section he went
groveling to president trump president
trump saw right through him did not
endorse him and then he endorsed me
everything president trump put in place
worked the reason memo keeps talking
about president trump's endorsement is
because he can't run on his own
positions president trump won
pennsylvania and president trump
endorsed me president trump was very
clear i'm america first i'm the only
person in this race that was appointed
by president trump you say that you are
america first you did so much for
president trump and yet he rejected it
thank you miss barnett once again trying
to tell pennsylvanians something that
president trump does not believe is true
president trump doesn't always get the
best advice i am the only conservative
voice no you're not dishonest dave is at
it again what president trump did he put
his finger on the fact that president
trump did was respect people who had
been othered forgotten cancelled
president trump coined the word mag up i
have discussed with president trump and
just like president trump that
experience is going to make me a better
senator so much so that president trump
on his teletown hall we need to enforce
the policies that worked under the trump
administration what president trump saw
right through him he therefore did not
endorse mr mccormick he endorsed me
president trump's policies trump was
able to put together operational warp
speed we saw under the trump economy all
right so you guys get the picture so
then it was an art first it was an
argument over who's lived in
pennsylvania the longest and long enough
then it was an argument over which of us
is the most liked by trump and most like
trump the funniest moment from the
entire thing was when dave mccormick who
seems to be kind of like the second you
know right up there with with mehmet oz
um and uh uh barnett they seem to be the
three front runners he said there's no
miracle cure which i love because you
know of dr oz's history as a guy
promoting all sorts of quack cures this
was that this was probably the funniest
moment and now he's flip-flopping and
the problem doctor is there's no miracle
cure for flip-flopping and
pennsylvanians are seeing right through
your phoniness and that's what you're
dealing with and that's why you're not
taking off in the polls so
that's actually great i mean dr oz
promoting you know drinkable silver and
various quack gears of different kinds
so that is actually pretty clever but
these are all absolutely terrible people
and unfortunately i hate to say this but
if i'm honest
the energy of any of these five
candidates likely would come off better
in a debate against the four democratic
candidates i saw yesterday i hate to say
it here's one last clip where
uh candidate sans attacks candidate
barnett for how how big her margin of
loss was in her previous election and
then they argue over who most believes
in the 2020 big lie in washington you
can count on me
they did not steal that election by 20
points she lost her last election to a
weak weak democrat john fetterman is not
a weak democrat he's strong i will beat
john fetterman in the fall thank you uh
i am going to give you 30 seconds to
respond thank you so much for that
because are you saying that there was
absolutely that that that the 2020
election was above par that there was no
fraud that there was no uh issues with
that
points are you telling me that it was
perfect and and if and because
apparently that's what she's saying so
for all of us in the republican party
now we have a candidate on stage carlos
sand who is saying that there was
absolutely nothing to see in that 2020
election but beyond that uh you know you
say that you are america first you did
so much for president trump and yet he
rejected it thank you miss barnett and i
did not give you that information
i'm gonna give you 15 seconds quickly to
respond to that
president trump doesn't always get the
best advice
there were actually times where each
candidate was given 10 seconds sometimes
to respond i mean it's the format
doesn't work the candidates are lunatics
the topics are absurd so it's all
very very depressing now why does
pennsylvania matter so much well when
you look at 270 to win.com they have a
number of different uh maps that you can
look at if you look at the 2022
consensus map pennsylvania is one of
only five senate toss-up states if you
look at sabato's crystal ball
pennsylvania is one of only four toss-up
states if you look at the cook political
map pennsylvania is one of five toss-up
states and in the politico map it's also
one of five toss-up states if you run a
number of different scenarios and
consider them
in a lot of them pennsylvania decides
whether democrats control the senate or
whether republicans control the senate
and unfortunately i didn't find any of
it particularly exciting let me know
your thoughts if you watch the debates
one of our longtime sponsors is vincero
collective if you don't know vincero yet
it's the place to go for quality watches
sunglasses and more
serious style
undeniable quality and total versatility
put vincero really at the top of the
game and their newest watch release
is no exception it's the argo automatic
it spotlights everything i love about
vincero i got the argo automatic in
frost white this is a dive watch which
is of course a staple in the watch world
but i really think vincero found a way
to make this one stand out i love the
gradient blue accent of the hour markers
against the solid white face i really
love all of their watches and i own a
bunch but the argo is probably my
favorite so far vincero sunglasses and
jewelry and other accessories are
awesome too an excellent way to elevate
any outfit vincero collective is giving
my audience fifteen percent off all
products and free shipping go to
vincerocollective.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below